[Musique]
dès cet automne
le zoom automatique
[Musique]
après cinq semaines d'une campagne
éclair qui avait cent mille morts dans
les rangs français l'armée allemande
entre dans paris déclaré ville ouverte
le 14 juin
harris est un esprit
[Musique]
un
pari un peu extirpé zapartistes at heart
is back
la cause
y'a rien de pommes
en cas d'erreur
enrique ortez fantôme lignes sont pures
offre au passage p 1
le 17 juin le maréchal pétain appelé à
cesser le combat tandis que des millions
de réfugiés fuient sur les routes
à l'appel
la direction du gouvernement de la
france je fais à la france
ce don de ma personne sera filmé pour
nadal c'est le coeur serré que je vous
dise aujourd'hui il faut cesser le bras
je me suis adressé cette nuit à
l'adversaire on lui demande et il est
prêt à rechercher avec loi entre autres
la lutte étendent les moyens de mettre
fin aux hostilités est un magazine
company
in need is love
unity 20% de femmes du community
[Musique]
22 juin à rethondes la délégation
française signe les convention
d'armistice qui sauvegarde des
apparences la souveraineté du
gouvernement est reconnu sur l'ensemble
du territoire y compris dans la partie
occupée par l'armée allemande
une ligne de démarcation coupe la france
en deux la france doit entretenir
l'armée d'occupation à un prix
exorbitant le potentiel militaire
français est neutralisée
de fait et comment sont d'armistice sont
le prélude une collaboration
franco-allemande l'armistice et l'acte
de baptême de vichy
[Musique]
alors est ce qu'on peut dire que à
l'armistice est le premier acte de la
collaboration
la réponse est laissée oui et non oui
dans le fond parce que
dans l'article 3 de la convention
d'armistice qui est aussi nié avec les
allemands le 22 juin 40 l'article 3 dit
que les autorités administratives
dans la zone qui sera occupé par les
forces d'occupation allemandes devront
sous amène arbeiten ça veut dire
travailler avec et donc qu'on peut
traduire par collaborer mais c'est un
terme disons technique dès lors que des
anglais contre toute attente vont
résister et françaises et les français
vont devoir vivre avec des clauses
d'armistice qui sont draconiennes et
alors le gouvernement français
maintenant le gouvernement de vichy va
essayer donc de vivre avec et on va
entrer alors dans la période de la
collaboration
[Musique]
où
dans la grande salle du casino de vichy
le 10 juillet les parlementaires sont
invités par laval à réviser la
constitution
quatre-vingts parlementaires sur les 600
sont douze présents refusent de voter
les pleins pouvoirs au maréchal pétain
celui ci a désormais les mains libres
pour abolir la république et créer
l'état français dont il est le chef
le gouvernement dirigé par laval
s'installe à vichy
le nom de vichy de me rallier à
l'histoire du relèvement français
l'hôtel du pain marque le centre de
cette cité nouvelle
de l'accord autour de chacun de ses
voyages le maréchal bien reprend la
lourde tâche de rebâtir tous ceux qui
dans ce pays menacé ruiz c'est là que le
maréchal travail
on peut estimer que la très grande
majorité des français a fait confiance à
philippe pétain ce vieillard glorieux de
84 ans vainqueur de verdun
qui ne semblait pas obsédé par le
pouvoir et qui surtout dans la très
grave crise d'identité nationale qui a
secoué la france dans l'été 40 pouvait
apparaître comme une sorte de bouclier
face donc aux nazis face en tous les cas
au vainqueur l'étain qui bénéficie d'une
immense popularité profitent de la
défaite de l'occupation allemande pour
effectuer un changement de régime et
impulser une révolution nationale qui
prône le redressement intellectuelle et
morale il s'agit de promouvoir les
valeurs traditionnelles de la famille du
travail de la discipline du respect de
l'ordre il faut rendre la france aux
français désigner l'étranger comme bouc
émissaire
dès octobre sans que les allemands ne
rien demander un statut des juifs est
promulguée quand on fait des individus
de deuxième catégorie
[Musique]
la révolution nationale attache une
importance particulière à la jeunesse
qu'il faut rééduquer en relais et
disciplinés les chantiers de jeunesse
sont ouverts
[Musique]
à flamengo l'espoir joyau
et nous travaillons sans
en digne fils de l'ohio
voilà vichy où chaque soir après une
journée de se soucier de labeur un homme
droite et tranquille proches au pavillon
des lignées comme un bon nous payer
après sa dure journée l'ouvrier qui
rebat qu'il en est un
aux côtés du maréchal laval a très tôt
fait le pari de la collaboration d'état
au nom du réalisme politique pour lui
l'allemagne a gagné la guerre debry nos
délégués de vichy en zone nord est sur
la même ligne bon nombre d'entre eux à
commencer par pierre laval on faire une
sorte de calcul disons géostratégique
ils vont se dire de toute manière
l'allemagne gagnera la guerre froide
donc il faut être du côté du vainqueur
il faut donc trouver sa place dans
l'europe allemande et trouver la
meilleure place possible
donc faire en sorte que le vainqueur
réserve au vaincu un sort privilégié ça
c'est le calcul géostratégique
pendant l'été 40 laval a des contacts
avec l'ambassadeur du reich en france
autour abete personnage une grande
habileté politique francophile qui tire
dans l'onglet ficelles avec beaucoup de
dextérité
[Musique]
l'un des drames politiques de la
collaboration d'état c'est que les
allemands n'était pas demandeur enfin il
faut bien le comprendre parce que
pendant longtemps l'historiographie
française a prétendu inverse en gros il
disait que hitler exiger la
collaboration et que pétain qui était un
super james bond avait brisé éviter tout
cela tout ça c'est faux c'est tout à
fait faux l'étude maintenant des
archives allemandes nous prouve tout à
fait inverse il terre n'était pas
demandeur pour une raison simple c'est
qu'il se défient très profondément de la
france pour des raisons on comprend
assez aisément
et que en tous les cas dans son esprit
il n'était pas question qui vient
partenariat franco allemand dans une
europe qui de toute manière serait
germanique bri à
bâle enfin la porte saint martin lys
sont madeleine martin grand boulevard
[Musique]
catherine
les candidatures n'ont pas été sans
doute à contacter meilleur rugbyman
bessel kok ont des besoins sont trop
profondes en titre sam hamad égalité
pour quelle raison malgré tout hitler
se décide à collaborer de temps à autre
enfin à sa manière avec avec le régime
de vichy bien il y trouve des tas
davantage l'avantagent c'est que il
préfère et il a préféré c'est le choix
dès le 18 juin 40
que la france soit gouvernée par un
gouvernement légal en l'occurrence
philippe pétain qui en plus est le
vainqueur de verdun qui vont auquel les
français se sont donnés dans leur très
grande majorité dans l'été 40 plutôt
qu'un gaulle ait heures plus tôt donc
qu'un allemand parce que avec 1go leiter
il faut amener beaucoup de police one et
beaucoup de gendarmerie vous gagnez
beaucoup de fonctionnaires allemands là
on a une administration française qui
est qui reste en dans la zone sud
jusqu'en novembre 42 qui continuent de
fonctionner sous la direction de
fonctionnaires français et qui en zone
occupée en zone nord donc travail et est
appelée essence et souza bernard breyton
travailler ensemble avec des autorités
d'occupation c'est beaucoup plus
efficace beaucoup plus rentables c'est
beaucoup plus efficace en particulier au
niveau de la sécurité de la verna
[Musique]
les tractations de l'été entre laval et
abete débouche sur montoir
le purin reçu monsieur lava ministre des
affaires étrangères et le maréchal
pétain les honneurs militaires lui rendu
aux deux hommes d'état français une
saisissant où le grand soldat que le
monde entier admire je montre devant le
vainqueur aussi grand qu'il fut héroïque
aux jours sombres de l'armistice
accompagné par le surprendre eventreur
ministre des affaires étrangères du
reich le chef de l'état race entretenir
de la reconstruction de l'europe avec le
führer gens ce levier dont les paroles
d'accueil rendront hommage à sa valeur à
son courage à sa sage est
là philippe pétain fait le choix
d'autres est de plain-pied
délibérément volontairement dans la
collaboration d'état politique pas
militaire économique et politique
c'est pourquoi c'est une coupure est une
date importante
pour maintenir l'unité française une
limite est de dix siècles dans le cadre
d'une activité constructive du nouvel
ordre européen
je joue aujourd'hui dans la voie de la
collaboration
cette politique la mienne des ministres
ne sont responsables tous devant moi et
moi seule l'histoire jugera comment
peut-on définir ce que les historiens
ont coutume d'appeler maintenant la
collaboration d'état c'est à dire c'est
la collaboration de l'état français du
régime de vichy avec leurs affiches
alors la définition la plus simple c'est
de dire que c'est la politique pratiquée
par le régime de vichy en vue d'obtenir
la coopération avec le reich c'est une
politique décidée par les responsables
des villes chi à commencer par philippe
pétain l'amiral darlan d'être désigné
par le maréchal
comme vice-président du conseil et
successeur éventuel du chef de l'état
le renvoi de laval le 13 décembre et son
remplacement par darlan n'est qu'une
révolution de palais elle ne change rien
à la politique de collaboration
à l'hôtel du parc siège du gouvernement
l'amiral darlan a fait l'exposé de ses
négociations avec le gouvernement
allemand et particulièrement des
résultats de son entrevue avec le
chancelier hitler autour du maréchal on
reconnaît l'amiral qui depuis plusieurs
mois même avec l'activité ces
tractations délicates avec l'approbation
rang caire du chef de l'état à
l'unanimité le conseil a approuvé le
rapport de l'amiral sur ces négociations
dont les effets se re commence à se
faire sentir dark l'ont
fait ceux se calcule à ce calcul assez
que une paix allemande ou d'allemagne
serait vainqueur est plus profitable à
la france de vichy qu'une paix anglo
saxon donc il vaut mieux avoir la pac
germanique a comme dit la paix allemande
que le triomphe des anglo saxons
pourquoi parce que pour diverses raisons
mais au moins une raison c'est que
darlan est un homme de la flotte est un
homme de la manne est un homme de l'
empire et pour lui l'ennemi celui qui
est devenu l'ennemi numéro 1 c'est la
grande bretagne c'est donc les peuples
de la mer et non plus donc l'allemagne
continental à paris se sont retrouvés et
regrouper les ultras de la collaboration
choqué par le renvoi de laval qui trouve
la révolution nationale bien molle et
adhèrent aux valeurs du national
socialisme
ils s'appellent eux-mêmes les
collaborationnistes
ce sont les hommes qui se sont le plus
engagées dans une
collaboration
avec le reich allemand une collaboration
tous azimuts c'est à dire non seulement
économique politique et militaire parce
qu'un premier point bien entendu il
partage avec les hommes de vichy des
mêmes motivations idéologiques
l'anticommunisme
l'antilibéralisme l'opposition à la
démocratie et à la république
l'antisémitisme mais deux points et
importants permettent de les
différencier très vite ils se
différencient au même très vite deux des
hommes de vichy c'est d'une part que
progressivement ou non leur idéologie
devient fascisant où se rapproche de
beaucoup de thématiques du fascisme et
ou du nazisme et puis deuxième point
encore une fois ils sont prêts non plus
à marchander ou à négocier avec un bail
mais à s'aligner avec al mal à concevoir
que non seulement on essaye de trouver
sa place mais qu' on est heureux de
d'être dans une allemagne nazie dans une
europe nazifié et que le seul moyen dans
le fond pour que la france puisse
retrouver la place c'est précisément de
se modifier elle-même dans la mosaïque
de groupuscules de l'ultra collaboration
émergent marcel déat un ancien
socialiste il dirige un journal l'oeuvre
qui tire à 130 mille exemplaires des as
ce normalien distinguer écrire à la
france s'il le faut se couvrir à deux
camps de concentration et les pelotons
d'exécution fonctionneront en permanence
l'enfantement d'un nouveau régime se
fait au forceps et dans la douleur au
début de 41 des avons le faire entre
harry à la salle wagram plus de 6000
personnes assistent au premier meeting
tenu par le rassemblement national
populaire exposé de monsieur dea
d'histoire je les prends seulement une
femme magnifique château chine est
français et c'est un jouet procès on
peut manger leurs membres - actuel de la
paix en europe commencent à s'apercevoir
que la presse écrit stentor et qu'elle
est folle histoire
vous faudra continuer d'exister
l'autre figure des collaborationnistes
de paris et doriot ancien communiste
grande gueule lui aussi un journal le
cri du peuple il a fondé le ppf en 36
excellent tribun il ne mâche pas ses
mots
victorieux à moitié de sa marine
commerciale est au fond
le tiers de sa marine de guerre
l'angleterre a perdu l'europe elle est
en train de perdre le peu d'influencé
qu'elle avait sur le continent
soviétique il perdra demain influence
qu'elle à 11 heures
l'angleterre est vaincu
ce qui nous intéresse c'est l'avenir de
la fin c'est son redressement c'est la
possibilité de lui maintenir comme la
ville maréchal son rang de grande
puissance européenne et coloniale
[Musique]
la lutte pour la défense de l'occident
est engagée la plus grande offensive et
jamais été menée au bourg de l'histoire
allait commencer
[Musique]
à l'ombre du 22 juin 1941 à la radio de
berlin dr goebbels ministre de la
propagande du reage donne lecture de la
proclamation du führer par laquelle ils
stigmatisent l'action du bolchévisme
russe y depuis plus de 20 ans et est
forcé par la duplicité de son action
diplomatique de mettre le feu à toute
l'europe
[Musique]
pour ces ultras de la collaboration
gênés dans leurs hôtes communisme
forcené par le pacte germano-soviétique
l'invasion de l'urss par la wehrmacht
est une divine surprise ils réclament
une collaboration militaire aux côtés du
rage et passe aux actes la légion des
volontaires français contre le
bolchevisme s'est constitué sa première
réunion a lieu au vélodrome d'hiver
l'exposé de marcel déat
même si demain le chalut mince je te
battre a confié dans les ports privé à
l'effort renault t il les chalets je
suis sûr que cela ou la mobylette ou la
copie raison simple jusqu'au bout et que
la pêche
les menti ce qui a été battu ce n'est
pas un pas de côté c'est la bonne
d'achalandage chine capitaliste qui
dirigeait
à dubaï où
la lutte qui est tombé contre le
bolchevisme
droit se terminer par son déclassement
sans changement du bolchevisme pendant
ce conflit
nous intéressant tant qu'européen
mais il nous intéresse aussi en tant que
pensaient
ils ont le tourner
si la france veut rester une puissance
européenne et mondiale si la france veut
rester digne il faut qu'elle se bat avec
elle pour le bo cheville il y apparaît
plus détendu
à versailles à la caserne pour nice
déborde que c'est rassembler le premier
contingent de la légion antivol subi les
trois couleurs s'élève dans le ciel de
l'ile-de-france pour la première fois
depuis 15 mois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à sa saison 2 c'est nous qui vous
défendre leur idéal l'idéal de la
révolution nationale la france et l'
aussie combattra pour la défense de la
civilisation menacée demain nos trois
couleurs le transall est mêlé aux
drapeaux de tous les alliés d'europe
demain la france sera présente dans le
combat décisif
d'où naîtra l'europe unie
doriot mettons ces actes en accord avec
ses idées par avec le premier contingent
de la lvf
l'un les vf ne tiendra pas les promesses
de ses promoteurs
les volontaires pour pourfendre le
bolchévisme ne sont pas légion pas plus
de onze mille inscrits pour toute la
guerre dont 2000 combattants
l'image devenue classique aux nouveaux
trains retraités versailles pour la
russie ces quelques centaines d'hommes
veut retrouver nos compatriotes qui aux
frontières de l'europe lutte afin que la
france prenne la place à laquelle vous
donne droit à la grandeur de son passé
et sa mission dans le monde
[Musique]
il ya des français qui partent mourir
pour berlin il ya ceux qui les incitent
à partir les combattants du micro radio
paris thomas des collaborationnistes
entre deux refrains anodin il distilla
bonnes paroles allemande comme jean
hérold pâquis qui terminent toutes ces
allocutions par un rituel
il ya ceux encore qui à défaut de fusil
tiennent leur plume par la gâchette les
partisans de l'engagement total aux
côtés des nazis dispose un journal bien
fait bien écrit où se côtoient de
redoutable bretteur
je suis partout et dirigée par robert
brasillach qui a commis quelques romans
remarqués il donne la ligne du journal
et
à je suis partout encore lucien rebatet
dans le livre les décombres remporté un
grand succès
céline donne libre cours à sa haine
antisémite lui qui écrivait à la veille
de la guerre dans bagatelles pour un
massacre
2 millions de bosch campé sur nos
territoires pourront jamais être pire
plus ravageur plus infamant que tous ces
juifs volent ou crevant les [__] au
moins c'est des blancs
et déni très fort ce que j'ai pu écrire
était fait justement contre la violence
le sentais mieux revenir je dénonçais
les motifs de la guerre
on a donné raison
drieu la rochelle prête sa plume au
journal tout en dirigeant la nrf la
nouvelle revue française avec la
bénédiction de la bête
artistes et écrivains prétend ambassade
ou l'institut allemand les plus
méritants sont habitent en allemagne ou
[Musique]
encore call
est arrivé au talent pur et le peur
qu'elles ne feront pas jamais la
continuité de certaines des cats est
certaine et dans la
[Musique]
d611
persiste
les éditeurs français ont fait preuve
d'une grande docilité envers l'occupant
ils ont accepté de mettre à l'index les
ouvrages condamnés par les autorités
allemandes et consignés sur la liste
auto
on y retrouve aragon carco kessel
malraux
la liste est précédé d'un préambule très
explicite désireux de contribuer à la
création d'une atmosphère plus saine les
éditeurs français ont décidé de retirer
des librairies et de la vente des livres
qui par leur esprit mensongers et
tendancieux ont systématiquement
empoisonné l'opinion publique française
sont visés en particulier la publication
de réfugiés politiques ou d'écrivains
juifs qui trahissent en l'hospitalité
que la france leur avait accordé on sans
scrupules poussait à une guerre dont il
espérait tirer profit pour leur but
égoïste les autorités allemandes ont
enregistré avec satisfaction
l'initiative des éditeurs français fin
de citation
2242 tonnes de livres interdits sont mis
au pilon
sous le signe de l'art des vedettes de
l'écran s'apprête à partir pour
l'allemagne à la gare de l'est on
reconnaît albert vrais gens
danielle darrieux
suzy delair
unis astor
viviane romance répondant à l'invitation
du docteur karl polish président de la
corporation du cinéma non ces artistes
seront pendant 12 jours les hôtes de
leurs camarades des studios de vienne de
munich et de berlin
les sculpteurs ont droit eux aussi à
leur voyage outre-rhin chez le maître
arnaud brecker que coupe tous célèbrent
avec émotion
on reconnaît notamment celui-là qui
pendant guen
l'anac
2 1
m
question d'image au sculpteur français
ont été accueillis dans les principales
cités d'art murray avant de regagner la
france ils visitent cet atelier où l'on
achève la construction d'un monument qui
sera érigé sur une grande place de la
capitale allemande
[Musique]
en échange les allemands avoye paris le
grand orchestre de berlin dirigé par le
jeune karajan
[Musique]
la france 11 heures graves que nous
traversons a reçu un nouveau
gouvernement à l'appel du maréchal le
président pierre laba à former un
nouveau ministère constitué sur de
nouvelles bases pour répondre aux
nécessités de la politique extérieure et
intérieure du pays le président pierre
laval en plus de sa fonction de chef de
gouvernement il dirigera les ministères
des affaires étrangères de l'intérieur
et de l'information
[Musique]
au printemps 42 sous la pression
allemande est un rappel laval qui n'a
pas varié d'un pouce de 1940 le nouveau
chef du gouvernement annonce clairement
la couleur
a une signification
et la volonté de rétablir avec
l'allemagne et avec l'italie
les relations normales et confiance
de cette guerre
surgira inévitablement une nouvelle
europe
pour construire cette europe l'allemagne
étant serein libre et des combats gym en
tête elle doit avec d'autres consenti à
dinan et accrétive elle ne ménage pas en
stationnaire
je souhaite la victoire de l'allemagne
parce que sans elle le bal fait dès
demain saint-andré partout on a
volontiers opposé un vichy pétain à
vichy laval et pétain on se passerait de
la collaboration d'état mais il est
contraint de l'assumer mais ce qui est
capital pour lui c'est de mettre en
oeuvre une révolution culturelle qu'il
appelle la révolution nationale et il a
besoin pour cela de la neutralité
bienveillante du reich l'aval d'une
foule à luis nationale c'est vraiment
pas sa tasse de thé en revanche le grand
dessein de laval c'est ça c'est que la
france puisse trouver sa place donc dans
une robe qui sera forcément allemand
afin de remplacer les travailleurs
allemands mobiliser les nazis ont besoin
de main d'oeuvre de beaucoup demandeur
au début il cherche à séduire les
travailleurs volontaires en vantant par
la propagande les mérites du travail en
allemagne qui est presque présentés
comme de grandes vacances
qui cherchent du travail en trouveront
en allemagne peut-on lire sur les murs
des villes françaises les ouvriers
spécialisés actuellement en chômage se
font inscrire au pas des services
officiels afin d'aller gagner leur vie
et celle de leur famille outre-rhin
ceci permet non seulement d'alléger
sensiblement les ferries de secours
accordé par l'état français mais aussi
de donner aux ouvriers l'occasion
d'apprécier la valeur des institutions
nationales socialiste allemande
ils sont 200 milles à se laisser tenter
mais cela ne suffit pas ça auquel le
grand négrier du raje réclame encore 250
mille travailleurs français laval avant
alors le système de la relève
[Musique]
plaçons la réponse des ouvriers français
à l'appel du président tous les centres
où ils se sont ouvert les bureaux
d'inscription des travailleurs pour
l'allemagne ont vu affluer et volontaire
l'appel à la grande relève et des
comprimés
grâce à ces départs des milliers de
prisonniers retenus jusqu'ici sur la
terre étrangère reverront leurs familles
ce n'est pas encore assez pour les nazis
lancer dans la guerre totale laval doit
restaurer le st lô
on peut dire que owen sept cent mille
français vont partir outre-rhin au titre
du service du travail obligatoire
c'est-à-dire des classes 20 21 22 trois
classes d'âge à partir du 16 février
1943 qui la loi dite du st lô
et on estime également que au début de
1944 au moins 4 millions de françaises
et de français sinon 5 millions travail
est soit dans leur h soit en france pour
la machine de guerre allemande ce qui
est quand même beaucoup
à paris mon petit palais se tient
l'exposition permanente de la technique
allemande afin de faire collaborer
étroitement les industriels ne paient
les fabricants allemands exposed ici non
seulement avec pièces détachées mais
aussi des appareils complet pour
lesquelles il cherche un fabricant en
france
l'industriel français choisit alors les
pièces qui lui est possible de fabriquer
on offre est aussitôt transmise aux
industries allemandes de kehl qui passe
d' économie française à idées
notablement l'économie de guerre du rage
de l'est qu'à partir de 1943
d'abord en fournissant un certain nombre
des matériels certain nombre de
matériels par exemple des camions des
camions fournis par berliet des camions
fournis par renault dès des appareils
qu'on pourra transformer en appareil
blindés toute la production aéronautique
française en particulier les moteurs
d'avions vont être livrés orages 100 %
de la production aéronautique française
qui va être maintenue par l'ue rage va
partir outre-rhin
peut dire que bonne partie sinon la très
grande majorité des entreprises
françaises d'une manière ou d'une autre
à commercer avec des entreprises
allemandes entre 40 et 44 et notamment
les banquiers qui ont fait des affaires
superbe à l'époque donc avec en ce et
bien en collaborant si en s'accommodant
donc de la logique industrielle ou
bancaire le gîte des affaires avec leurs
homologues allemands et de toute manière
si on regardait bien passé au peigne fin
un certain nombre de fortunes de gens
qui ensuite vont s'étaler après la
libération dont on constaterait que le
point de départ par des années noires et
cette collaboration de type économique
c'est la collaboration qui sera la plus
difficile à pister et qui sera également
celle qui sera la moins réprimées
[Musique]
deux jours après son retour au pouvoir
laval nomme rené bousquet secrétaire
général à la police le destin de ce haut
fonctionnaire radical socialiste qui a
prêté serment à pétain comme tous les
préfets bascule
en suivant sa tournée à travers la
prendre sur rené bousquet secrétaire
général à la police ayant à ses côtés
son intendant général et le préfet de la
région inspectent le groupe urbain de la
police auquel s'est joint le groupe
mobile de réserve de création récente et
nous voyons ici pour la première fois
aux actualités
[Musique]
dynamique ambitieux bousquet qui
n'adhérent rien aux idées national
socialiste met son talent au service de
laval et réorganise la police au même
moment deux nouveaux hommes sont mis en
place au sommet de la hiérarchie
policière allemande en france
arrivé de monsieur et griffes général
des fn chef de la sûreté représentants
du reich à prague chargé par le chef des
ss et de la police allemande monsieur
himmler d'installer dans ses fonctions
monsieur robert pires général de
division des ss et la police en
territoire occupé on sait que la
commission internationale de la police
criminelle a pour président monsieur
pays riches et que la france a toujours
été représenté à cette commission
[Musique]
le général a profité de son séjour à
paris pour recevoir monsieur bousquet
[Musique]
bousquet négocié avec heydrich et
hohberg les modalités de la
collaboration entre les polices
française et allemande dans la lutte
contre la résistance et obtient que la
police française ne soit pas subordonnée
aux allemands
mais au moment même où bousquet avec un
zèle de hauts fonctionnaires cherche à
sauvegarder l'autonomie de la police
française les allemands exige la
collaboration de vichy dans la
déportation des juifs de france la
solution finale a été décidé et mis en
route par hitler les juifs de france
victimes de l'antisémitisme d'état mise
à l'écart par une statue de 40 rafler et
parquet pour ceux qui sont d'origine
étrangère des 41 sont contraints de
porter l'étoile jaune enjoint 42 en zone
nord
[Musique]
mais lui
on
[Musique]
nous
la question juive comme on l'appelait à
l'époque va être partie prenante de la
collaboration d'état lorsque pierre
laval revient au pouvoir il va
comprendre très vite que
à tort ou à raison laval poste
spécialement dit scéniquement fin ce qui
intéresse toute chose c'est qu'il va
comprendre que hitler et les nazis font
de l'extermination des juifs de la
solution finale une question
fondamentale alors laval n'hésite pas où
il existe très peu
il faut on va donc dans un véritable 30
l'humain sacrifier les juifs puisque
c'est capital pour le maintien les
progrès de la collaboration d'état en
juillet 42 il a maintenant nous avons
tous les textes nous permettent le dire
pierre laval et son représentant rené
bousquet qui le secrétaire à la police
vont prêter
les policiers gendarmes français pour
opérer les raf fait alors quand les
juifs étrangers à la demande donc des
des autorités donc répressive du sd
allemand donc des de la gestapo de la
gestapo allemande
les 16 et 17 juillet 42 des policiers
français arrêtent 12880 quatre enfants
femmes et hommes qui sont parqués au
vélodrome d'hiver avant d'être transféré
dans l'étang de drancy ou pithiviers
antichambre david
je
entier que la police française a réalisé
jusqu'ici une tâche digne d'éloges écrit
le ss hohberg le 22 juillet à rené
bousquet
en zone sud sur instruction bousquet
6000 juifs sont rappelés par la police
française est remis aux allemands
et en mettant les fonctionnaires
français au service des allemands a été
un rouage essentiel de la déportation
des juifs vivant en france
[Musique]
le 8 novembre 1942 les anglo saxons
débarque en afrique du nord
[Musique]
entre autres conséquences l'action anglo
américaine contre notre empire africain
a contraint des troupes allemandes à
franchir la ligne de démarcation afin
d'aller occuper nos côtes
méditerranéennes
[Musique]
dans la rade de toulon la flotte se
saborde l'invasion de la zone sud met
fin à la fiction d'un état français
indépendant les arguments de vichy pour
justifier la collaboration d'état
s'effondre il n'y a plus de territoire
indépendant plus de forces armées plus
de flotte plus dans pire
[Musique]
mais
en janvier quarante-trois laval décide
de créer la milice il ne dispose plus en
effet de l'armée d'armistice des armées
sous la pression des collaborationnistes
de paris qui réclame toujours plus de
répression la balle a besoin d'une garde
prétorienne
il s'appuie sur le service d'ordre
légionnaire le sol créé et animé par
joseph darnand
[Musique]
à
une école des cadres de la milice est
créé au château d'uriage
dans
désormais la france garde bien entraîné
les mises en place
[Musique]
un journal combat en cas parole du chef
entre deux exhortation on trouve des
chroniques de colette ou de mac orlan
darnand combattants des deux guerres va
jusqu'au bout de sa logique de
collaborations armée avec l'occupant il
prête serment à hitler et devient
commandant de la ss
[Musique]
au cours de l'année 1943 la milice
instruments de vichy mais dirigée par
les collaborationnistes
[Musique]
où
un commun aux côtés de la wehrmacht
[Musique]
hiver 30000 parisien de toutes classes
sociales assiste à une manette
sophisme est de recréer l'ordre français
se succèdent à la tribune joseph darnand
référence et nous
j'en ai relevé qu' il n'y a pas de
solution water
françaises et français
pioneer du front de l'est
en france
marcel déat l'époque motif le jour où
les gens vont américain ray shero de
mettre le pied sur le podium il n'est
pas possible qu'il ne se redresse pas
devant fait une nation au patin semblait
armé
[Applaudissements]
ultime étape de la prise du pouvoir par
les partisans de la collaboration armée
le 30 décembre 43 joseph darnand patron
de la milice commandant de la ss devient
secrétaire d'état au maintien de l'ordre
la milice et avec elle la frange la plus
dure de la collaboration est entrée au
gouvernement
autres miliciens philippe henriot
militants avant guerre d'une droite
catholique et conservatrice qui a
basculé parenti bolchévisme dans le
collaborationnisme enragé chroniqueur
redoutable et très écouté de radio vichy
devient responsable de la propagande du
gouvernement on nous dit que nous ne
sommes pas des patriotes parce que nous
acceptons la politique de collaboration
avec l'allemagne parce que nous pensons
qu'il y a là une opération européenne
indispensable
on nous dit que nous ne sommes pas des
patriotes nous acceptons le fait de la
défaite comme avant le peur on cible
après est aussi déchiré que vous mais
entendons partir de là courageusement
pour faire les efforts nécessaires et
remonter avec des méthodes français sous
les chefs transfert pour assurer un
relèvement français et c'est vous qui
nous dit que nous sommes pas des
patriotes vous qui avez tellement perdu
la foi dans notre patrie que vous le
côté plus que sur l'étranger pour lui
rapporter ce cas la période
[Applaudissements]
sous l'impulsion d'arnaud la milice
investi l'état est pure l'administration
place ses hommes et avec la bénédiction
des allemands vient jusqu'en zone nord
parader sur les champs elysées dans la
cour d'honneur des invalides me et
nouveau hangar devons prêter serment
devant leur chef joseph darnand
derrière darnand dernière ces miliciens
on voit donc se profiler un état
miliciens à l'intérieur du régime de
vichy un état d'autant plus redoutables
qu'ils contrôlent maintenant toutes les
polices les médias avec philippe henriot
et même le système pénitentiaire car de
plus en plus de miliciens sont à la tête
des grandes centrales pénitentiaire donc
est en train de se mettre en place une
sorte de système totalitaire
war réseau totalitaire à l'intérieur de
ce régime de vichy alors que darnand et
c'est son entourage et principaux
responsables ont basculé totalement du
côté du rage sont en fait des
collaborationnistes d'autant plus que il
joue la carte et cessent et que les ss
appuie ces miliciens
homme noir des années noires les
miliciens quadrille assassine font
régner la terreur
chan garde des troupes allemandes ils
sont lâchés contre les maquis celui des
glières en février 44 et élimine avec
sauvagerie les résistants qui leur
tombent entre les mains
les francs garde qui ont participé au
nettoyage du plateau des glières arrives
tu à vichy mais hélas plusieurs de leurs
camarades ne sont plus des soldats de
l'ordre ont donné leur vie pour défendre
le pays contre le crime et le banditisme
comment hop et a réagi à cette évolution
de son état français
il va couvrir la milice jusque en 1944
puisqu'on a parlé de la milice parce que
c'est un obsédé de l'ordre et que il
n'admet pas un quelconque d or dès que
jusqu'au bout il va être convaincu de la
justesse de son choix de départ c'est
d'abord un problème de révolution
nationale d'un problème donc de le
nationalisme se joue d'abord à
l'intérieur contre l'anti france contre
les nuits intérieur bon et ça ne
demandera jamais
[Musique]
le maréchal et gris de plus en plus
isolé entreprend au printemps 44 une
tournée en zone nord au cours de
laquelle il peut mesurer que sa
popularité est encore vivace
aujourd'hui le coeur de paris à part les
maris ou depuis tant de siècles bat le
coeur de la france et du fond de notre
désarroi du fond de notre malheur surgit
un nouvel espoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
à
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'on sème le droit se mêler à ce
conflit autrement ce serait vraiment
table pour vous et pour la france
accepter des épreuves qu'on nous envoie
ce ces preuves sont terribles mais elles
seront d'autant moins terrible que vous
n'y prendrai pas part
ayez confiance dans l'avenir de la
france
[Applaudissements]
alors
[Musique]
nous sommes menacés au corps une
invasion de la peau qu'est-ce qui se
passera à tout moment dans ce cas encore
un sujet d'inquiétude et une
interrogation se pose
d'un gazon tout cela va-t-il durer
[Musique]
pour les jusqu'au boutistes de la
collaboration de département ne change
rien
imperturbable orio continue à vitupérer
les premières photos des villes normand
qui convoitent camp mais on se demande
si les histoires du conquérante veilleux
et des processions de sion face dans les
rues encombrées d'une full tilt et j'ai
pleuré brandi des drapeaux dont on été
inventé à vide en tant que deux gratuits
après le débarquement les miliciens
darnand redouble de violence et de
férocité contre les résistants
encourager de la voix et du geste par
henriot
[Musique]
la résistance des sites d'abattre le
porte-parole de l'état munitions
[Musique]
le débarquement allié en provence le 15
août déclenché de sauve qui peut
craignant d'être prise en tenaille les
porte-voix des porte-plumes les
porte-flingues de la collaboration
s'enfuit vers l'allemagne
la piétaille débris de la milice de la
lhbbf de la waffen ss française est
enrôlé par les allemands dans la
division charlemagne
la plupart de ses 7500 homme va aller
mourir sous l'uniforme allemand sur le
front de l'est
le gratin de vichy de paris
collaborateurs et collaborationniste
échoue d'abord à baden baden où encore
une ville d'eau comme en témoignent les
registres d'hôtel
puis dorion faisons toujours cavalier
seul trait avec l'appui des allemands un
comité de libération française
les autres sont regroupés à 6 clarin que
dans les châteaux d eau le tonnerre
emmenés de force près salma s'enferme
dans un silence bourgault
à l'étagé en dessous darnand dérape de
rhinau continue de s'agiter de compléter
pour maintenir un état fantoche
se perpétue un rituel d'opérette
ils émettent sur les ondes et crée même
un journal
tout cela est dérisoire
une communauté réduite aux cac et dire à
un spécialiste l'aube rouge à l'ancien
plumitif de je suis partout
céline est là aussi plus tard il décrira
dans d'un château l'autre cette fin
d'équipé pitoyable qui aurait pu
s'appeler voyage au bout de la nuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il était normal qu'ils aboutissent là
dans cette bourgade de würth inverse oui
aujourd'hui de bruit des chars français
il se réfugie si dans ce château des
hohenzollern mes hommes qui par peur par
ambition ou par bassesse ont trahi la
france et les français la route de pissy
conduisait pasig marine guen
[Musique]
metin de brienon l'aval des as où vécut
dans ses salons naguère fréquentée par
bismarck où nos soldats haute encore
trouver des journaux imprimés en
français mais écrit en allemand
quant à pétain
changer de paysage et si l'on en croit
la bouteille il a laissé il a aussi
changé de régime
[Musique]
l'écroulement du reich dispersent et
invités du château est un contre
volontairement en france
après l'hôtel du parc après le château
de sigma ring game c'était les deux
pièces nues du prisonnier où pétain
solitaire n'avait pu s'entretenir avec
ses avocats et ses souvenirs et
maintenant c'est le palais de justice et
c'est la voiture cellulaire
et voici que pétain entre dans la salle
de la première chambre propre petite
salle pour un si grand procès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
et
[Musique]
bon
m
e
où
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
et